What you are about to see is one of the most transformative parts of modern statistics
and it uses things if like we've never seen before.
We start out with the binomial distribution that you're familiar with from our last unit
and then we move into the central limit theorem which basically means
we take a number of coin flips to infinity.
From that, we arrive at the normal distribution which is basis to so much in statistics--
all of testing and confidence intervals are defined though the normal distribution.
And the reason why this matters is much of what we've done in coin flips had one or two coin flips
but in statistics experiments, you often have 1000 of patients or 1000 of data points
and then starting the normal distribution as an approximation
to the binomial distribution is much more practical.
So let's start--so when we start with our now well established formula for binomial distributions
where N is the number of coin flips, k is how often it comes up with heads
and p is the probability that the coin comes up with heads, usually 0.5.
And I want to graph for fix n this function here. K can go from 0 all the way to 20.
Instead of letting you compute this thing over here for all those different values of k,
I'm going to ask a different question--suppose you have a fair coin,
what do you think this value takes on its maximum value, which value of k maximizes our expression.
I know you can't really know this but with some thought,
I believe you'll arrive at the correct answer.